le couperet est tombé pour les ouvriers
delti forêt se méfie le 25 juillet sauf
improbable repreneur une procédure de
licenciement et de liquidation sera
lancée devant le tribunal de commerce de
paris
pour hervé corte 35 ans dans
l'entreprise les dernières illusions se
sont envolés comme tout le monde on
croit pas au père noël
voilà j'aurais bien voulu finir ma vie
ici mais accepta parti pour la rage
l'air une nouvelle apprise de la bouche
d'avocats alors que le patron du groupe
a annulé sa venue en dernière minute
celui de son nom n'existe pas les
bruyants drôle c'est que de la magouille
à haut niveau et puis nous on est rien
non on prend les choses à plat un faux
et que c'est tout pour les 115 salariés
les annonces sont difficiles à avaler
l'été dernier ils se sont battus pour
une reprise altit forts s'étaient
engagés à investir et ne pas licencier
pendant deux ans aujourd'hui ils se
sentent trahis
on ya cru on a fait le nécessaire on a
chaud mais on a travaillé on s'est fait
fort mais on a fait beaucoup de choses
on a donné le temps est en fait en
arrière et on n'aura rien au bout de la
faune avec la fermeture du site ce sera
la fin de plus de 60 ans d'une aventure
ah koon au départ une petite société
familiale devenue deuxième plus grosse
entreprise industrielle du secteur
un symbole qui suscite déjà des regrets
pour le maire moi je connais monsieur
cendres qu'il a créé à l'époque et pour
nous c'est quelque chose plus
qu'important parce que c'est l'histoire
c'est l'histoire de ce système de
soudure par friction qui a été inventé à
cosne c'est vraiment dommage on a un
savoir faire
les machines les hommes la qualité et on
a tout gâché
un nouveau coup dur également pour
l'activité à cosne-sur-loire en 2016
l'industrie ne représentait déjà plus
que 15% des emplois